a young doctor cares for a baby just a
few days old but soon vitalina May hold
the life of a soldier in her hands she
plans on volunteering to be a front-line
medic in Ukraine's war with
Russia I understand that the risk are
quite high but we live in Ukraine and
there is even a risk of dying here No
One Ever Knows their fate I'm ready to
take these risks
now she made up her mind when a close
friend was killed on the battlefield but
she has not told her parents
yet starting from October the 1st
Ukraine's defense Ministry has ordered
women with medical backgrounds to
register for military service unlike men
they won't be restricted from leaving
the country unless mobilized for active
duty a record number of women have
already signed up to
fight exenia and her husband run a
nonprofit organization providing
equipment and uniforms specific ly
tailored for women filling a gap in the
supply
chain in the beginning we had 30
requests per month now is more than 50
requests per day it can be for basic
uniform underwear a bulletproof vest or
a helmet even a drone a car or a
paramedics
backpack each box leaving the warehouse
is personal xenia's sister-in-law is on
the front line and her husband was
killed in
action we often receive requests and the
next day half of these are not needed
because the people have died recently we
sent one of our girls a parcel with her
uniform she was very happy 2 days later
she was
dead tens of thousands of women have
volunteered and are serving in Ukraine's
military for now the mandatory
registration for women applies only to
the medical profession and while there
are no plans to go beyond that it is
something that could change the longer
the war drags
on operation ukrainians began
volunteering when The Invasion happened
but the military acknowledges not
everyone is Keen to
fight no one is born for war a child is
not born knowing that it will be
necessary to go to war and fight
everyone is scared and it's really scary
and all our heroes both men and women
until the first artillery
barrage oana says women choosing to
serve in Ukraine's armed forces are
taking on medical combat and Leadership
roles
warrior women defending their
motherland Zan basravi Al jazer
keev make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer